my ice cream like chocolate I like pizza
and cheese like a dude is hurt ain't
dance night dance Steven I just got
dance oh my god
[Music]
where's fire team ever podcast and the
water alive episode 5 oh yeah
so anyway so I was gonna use my so go
back to this I want to talk about so
let's talk about favorite time so it was
like you're one of your favorite time so
this is my favorite because it reminds
me of like how would I even fall out I
could you know know there's my favorite
gunsmith bounties because he's you used
to be mr. Venus one part which my goes
to the VEX was in the other section so I
would love doing gunsmith bounties when
I'm about to rank up yeah and I knowing
that when I go back to the tower
you know Banshee would have like a gun
waiting that's like my thing ever did
those that's so fun well you did it I
started then I stopped because I was
like this is the worst yeah speaking was
those some of those piss me off like the
last word anything remember yelling [ __ ]
that was like 400 people and he never
yeah and it and it was only to take away
if you went negative in a game yeah dude
I never gun I don't know how people got
that the hardest bounty for any gun was
Thor yeah oh yeah you're one year to
because they had that either had that
set fixed prime that was like well you
got to the end it was super hard yeah no
no no not separate try the one with the
with the ogre at the end which was
that's a word yes super well you're
running a circle
and you you had a good a pillar that had
to be a random drop from turning in
bounties to right what Thorne warmest oh
yeah whatever when you got but I've seen
two complete deform quests don't only
thanks so much of the foreign quest was
getting the swords the sword was such a
grind with yet serious
oh my god yeah yummy - Steve you can
find other people do the raid and I know
you're going these message boards that
was a big that's not with Bobby yeah
bombs started going out and doing it
random yeah yeah Bobby this thing though
but first of all I had people I was
playing with oh no no I was playing
yesterday in the car I didn't start
playing destiny with Bobby I was already
playing destiny way he were playing
destiny yeah oh so I had a groups of
people are already playing destiny with
and I was telling Bobby I was like dude
yeah actually I introduced Bobby don't
wanna my destiny friends really and that
side he started that's how we did weird
raids and stuff in the beginning so I
introduced it to my face but then he was
like we should have our own group cuz I
can only play with that kid like in the
middle of the day so then we got that's
when we got our own groups because we
played at night
we you know you me in the early morning
at 7 a.m. yeah yeah nice everything will
be like Bobby we don't you come on and
like you know somebody's playing jump
into the party and just be like yeah
this is some dishonorable yeah with
disloyalty was like yeah I'm not gonna
play and then I logged in and then I
like turned it like prior real quick and
then I just remember playing a nice well
like everybody would get upset with each
other because Steve wanted to play
there's so many people are doing there's
a you know terrible but playing all you
guys friends first church taking jujitsu
classes like now I'm great at this and
then your other I just didn't understand
cuz I would be headshotting you just to
clarify I'm dead just to clarify it
wasn't it was you versus the three of
them right
you took you all in there you were there
too I don't think it was no I did one
verse for I've done one verse all you
guys he was giving me the most
that's why I always when I win you even
like one killer I feel like it's like a
win I think it was funny though I feel
like I remember it because like there
was a time at all it was all on burning
strength but I ran into Craig like five
times in a row and this [ __ ] is
trying to shoulder tar me to every city
Craig coming at me I would just [ __ ] one
shot handcannon 409 did it like five
what about the time I played you a
Gavin's against Steven oh yeah we they
won they've no no they BOS you and hey
they beat us because against me dad was
a gavel is getting this when you guys
switched yeah yeah because Steven be and
especially with Steve when I played like
I were playing against Bobby and I was
playing against him and I killed him
once if I did he would just crowd what
the Lord of wolves behind the corner he
was a coward he would not move he would
literally can't the whole Tiger mansion
he would camp
yeah my favorite I think would be well
cuz I first started playing with you
guys when I was working at the store
like when I first ever working at the
store yeah so like the only time and you
know what Steve
we gotta get Frank yeah like for me when
you're young your head it's like Bobby
and Eric you know those guys are like
working comments and stuff so I'd always
get to like I always loved bugging them
about destiny and talking with my
favorite though is one Eric about which
black dude
it's a different this made me laugh so
hard because I was like oh I'm gonna do
this every [ __ ] time now just a [ __ ]
if I remember those of it you would even
say a word
shut up it's so funny cuz i crack jokes
all the time I just yeah crickets what's
the interesting story go see Detroit
okay
I heard that wasn't good though is it
good now um what is it how am I gonna
tire of those type of movies anything
white cannot move you're not annoyed
guilt movies or not or white war movies
yeah white war movies are the worst it's
already or white masturbation movies
I like that Griffin did it yeah yeah you
see response that was such a freaking
throw it like a joke and it'll just and
you know because you kind of set it up
Frank always like as that moment when
you hear the funny is when Griffin's on
because Griffins are saying what's
funnier actually saying something that's
gonna make air Gruber lamp we're saying
something that said no era Griffin
annoying made all of us laugh I think
it's funny I think it's funny when a it
was funny too because it changed it in
the beginning you were all about the
whole are like every night you would get
on that was probably drove us crazy over
at the beginning because you'd be like
yo are the orm bur Franklin always been
telling Huey
this will enjoy it you know bring us in
your [ __ ] when Frank comes around we're
gonna give a rose to God if he wins he's
gonna be
they become alright god I remember it
was at the store Bobby came up any like
cracked a joke towards me and then I was
just like no today's the day and then I
hit him with one it was so harsh to him
because remember he's always like you're
not doing whatever terrible you're not
going to brain a now yes so execute on
one date did but every day was like
you're not going to but then go is
backhanded cuz then you like you were
talking he's like alright now shut the
[ __ ] up frames yeah don't get a big head
in bag yeah wait I guess the favorite
moments like are still the early days we
were playing doing quadrant yeah
finishing those 34 just the first time
we did it just like the Sun is coming in
my window yeah the sun's come in window
we finally finish it we were just like
we can't believe it let's just say then
you just go back to the reef you do it
all again
waking like when you're like all right
we're done playing and then like you get
up and it's like oh yeah just say you
don't even know it was like bright early
morning like it's your routine it was
like you did the weekly strike with all
the characters oh yeah
the builders on every single character
you know we try to do it it was almost a
tough times
that's the stuff I remember today then
they just kept changing trials yeah so I
don't know if I like the changes I guess
they're good but at the same time I'm
like cuz it's areas of the game that you
don't even go to like we're like when's
the last time you've been to Venus right
I just remember you know brother Vance
is at the bottom I never knew what that
was I wish I'd never walk down there and
then have before member of their own
gear you can see the gear yeah we'll be
like this yeah the red zone this was
this was when we were playing the
private matches with gas because we were
talking about that rifle you're like oh
yes we can do it
[Music]
and you're super pumped to play this
game I know
so we're getting talked to a lawyer and
he's like you know know that this gun
it's good and gas you know making fun
talking about he's killing us with this
year one auto rifle and I can't even
beat a guy with but that was like the
worst day anyway I realized like oh by
the way I got this game that game
injustice is a waste of money
because you want to talk about like this
to go on and these people are just yeah
that's our destiny could be well I
remember one of the most like
frustrating and stressful was me and
your brother because he wanted it was a
great win the new town you know it was
he's already hates me well here's the
thing here's the thing like it was me
and him and we were playing we were like
low light and we were playing with the
nightfall judge me and him the new one
yeah yeah and I was like he's like we
should do it and we play this ogre and
there's 8,000 characters just annihilate
and
your voice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dismantling mine I hated them
dismantling mines part would be like
especially you know the hardest one was
that that the Cabal area three science
there's a solo but that was the new but
those hardest [ __ ] the other one we
could play those things kept coming down
we would die yes so hard I can't play it
would've been cool to bring two guys
faster than a blink
but going on because we talked about it
on your podcast like seeing who's the
best of the worst
I feel like coach is always like we
gotta bring the game we don't do a lot
of and the reason is because it just
gets to be too much as when we do play
private matches with all of us because I
would you know is the most frustrated
yeah when you're playing with us if any
of us kill you you come clean and say if
you took down Bruce Lee with my sticky I
would be waiting a classic coke move is
that your fighting you know he wants to
come in with a super and I clean when
I'm playing with you
we're with him and I get killed and he's
like super me playing the Cather man but
that's why we don't do private cuz we
would get any time I killed Steve a
movie play you again I can tell I get
sensitive eyes oh yeah
thank that i don't like singing i will
you just burning shrine memory I was
like oh cap see but whatever I was more
like a flag I was in the corner of the
room bridge he looks at me I would
always go for myself well because we get
tired well you get burned up I mean the
thing with it is like you're getting
tagged by people from like across the
frickin map that are looking at they got
down on a screen in your day okay and
then you're like husband
instead let mine I'm going back to the
black field when we get we got into it
in France hobos yeah okay
black jail yeah it was trials and I kept
telling them to go outside and take the
point I remember what it was this is
what pissed me off
we're losing the entire time yeah oh
there well he keeps going inside we go
to the catcher we win I just don't like
it because I can't use my shotgun
because no but here's the thing for me
and Steve probably more me I was not
playing with like your guns have range
so you right but your hand cannon as
range but every time we go outside
because you Steve you're there with me
sometimes you'll get tagged to by
snipers yeah so like when we go outside
and you said it with me because we've
done it together we had tagged a lot
because they're on the other side of the
map just sniping we did that in dungeon
and we did really really well
oh you're right what I'm saying is with
with snipers you're you're talking about
snipers long distance right right what
was the problem with you got black
shield when you go inside if they're
sneaking with icebreaker which thank you
they head glitch the spot
well let's go we have to go to them well
let's go to that's where you let's go to
this though that's the thing to the maps
changed I even you hate certain maps
because you know that they the way that
people play
yeah so it's it's I mean that's the
thing with that frustrates me sometimes
is like depending on the map depending
on who you're playing against depending
on what they're using it affects how you
play and then when you guys say they
call it's not fauna I'm not having fun
with how it gets for me we found outside
game tagging all the time but you're not
even get why was that I was in sight
outside no because you're waiting with
your let them come to us and then Frank
start to match the Steve goes kill two
people he goes that's it that this is a
new thing just a wipeout City I looked
up this video the PDX it's it's better
than the grass you gotta get you got to
get the we gotta bring this up you gotta
bring this up lag switching between you
so is my fault
the flanking
ah I tagged two of them I tagged to move
my grenade there up in the middle that's
nice [ __ ] lag switching dude huh yeah
yeah one guy was lagging bad dude
where is this dude goddamn oh oh what
was this
they're lagging hard me I know that's
what I'm saying
that's what I said last round I killed
the guy and took him like ten minutes to
die
yeah these guys are like there are so
many people we didn't in the beginning
because it was like that's a server
issue but a lot of these nerds beat you
because I get messages from them that's
what all the time I get messages so they
instigated they talk [ __ ] but they don't
use any customers so if I said I don't I
didn't know how the system worked I sent
something back with a cuss word in it
they report it and Xbox doesn't even
look into the conversation because
obviously there's so many people that
have never reported right they just had
a search thing that searches for
customers and if it does they block you
so that's how I got bla I didn't even
initiate it I would just say that you
know I got a foul mouth but you know
it's funny is like Steve hates out
Coker damn or somebody and they were
like they were like I'm gonna I'm gonna
message break free don't do it 30
because he thinks they're just gonna
play like way better now cuz I diss them
you know and it's really Steve just
getting in his own add life yeah yeah
but but no that [ __ ] was funny because
it like we were playing well and then I
saw Steve's gameplay go because he was
freaking out like yeah well Steve's done
a confrontationally he gets to the red
zone but otherwise you're not a very
confrontational guy well it's just
pressure like it's like a big something
puzzled oh yeah use the last kinda 14
that's it yeah two guys from prison of
elders you a way to get out of things
would be like to take a lap it's like
we're in the middle of shooting it it
seems like in the early days was like
you really you got to play with us
you're gonna play with us just
everything just get on destiny yeah and
like I get on and like Bob and Griffin
are just giving you so much [ __ ] I just
he is freaking out
thank you on about just being and I
think you know there's something fun
about just having just [ __ ] talking
between everybody that's what yeah
that's what handle love the better we
shall sit and she'll listen to us all
[ __ ] talk each other and she thinks the
funniest thing in the world
yeah it is we are the worst
why would say we're the worst you know
the worst but I mean it's funny but
there there have been weird times like
like there's I hate cheaters oh hey you
know what I need is when I get messages
cuz I got sucking already and then some
[ __ ] wants to send me by the way you
suck like I don't know you got a
reminder messages you play with people
and listen your misters noob yeah and
the only one that goes back to his code
does that count as I give up at that
point I like it you know I like talking
I only got one message and it was from
my kid who's like I know you're cheating
my uncle works at Xbox we said my uncle
or except Xbox that was the funniest
like his uncles he's the owner of Xbox
yeah there's been a lot of times when
you guys are playing are you just on you
know and you jump in a group with some
people or whatever and then they just
start their nonsense and I just go by
the way they talk I'm just saying I
don't know you well that's that's why
Bob I always want to really get angry
because before this before that I
remember I know he's been like hey let
me know be the ready he was like nah man
[ __ ] you I got my guys these guys are
the best these are my boys all right
cool and then I heard this story and I
was like that is hilarious where I owe a
clean up growing up oh no no so yeah he
was like playing one of them kids one of
the raids and then like one of the guys
is saying you know kid one of the guys
is saying this I think it's gonna arrows
Star Wars he was like
you know you're supposed to do this in
everyone's like and then he was like oh
sorry I was with you guys how to do it
we were just laughing I wish people
would come on with us though it would be
like oh you guys are fun you know we get
heat it with each other but we don't but
it's not the game it's just a husband
like the games you can't come in with
your other outside [ __ ] actually when it
turns to late don't come in talking
about like one of my pet peeves on
destiny biggest biggest destiny pet
peeve you're playing a raid okay you're
going is taking some time you know say
we've done it three four times and
there's somebody just quits without
saying anything I can't stand that the
whole process of finding somebody new
it's like just check out just say hey
guys I don't want to play like this
anymore I got to go but then another one
as I also can't stand like people think
like they forget that it still should be
fun like you're doing the raid like some
comes in and they're like got it you
losers take it so long like you know my
other group would have done this already
having some fun like you know thank you
that we're not doing it in ten minutes
or and no it's so funny he's like
whatever being groups like that I always
be just one dude the whole everyone else
is laughing around random people that
would join this one just have so much
fun to do you guys are [ __ ] hilarious
always be that one guy and that's why we
just didn't like play with us
that's right well Bobby and I though
that's the whole first thing that Bobby
and I were like we were like now because
we were trying to be like yeah who's
that
and then we don't want to talk to people
right so then we're like this to people
then you know got Steve in they were
like we gotta get other people because
we wanted to do the raids as we didn't
want to do it with other people I mean
another thing too when you do do that
like especially through the app a lot of
those people add you as friends
and like even me I added a bunch sisters
like that's whatever but now when I do
it and I open it up like I don't even
know I don't either
yeah like in the beginning you just
never think after a while you're like
cuz you know I want to play the people
we know I want to have fun I don't want
to go in there yeah
boy they even with the trials going back
to trials like it's uneventful it would
have been in that folder we did it with
our core group getting somebody that was
my point that was my point like like
winning with that guy to me was the most
like it was depressed me yeah it wasn't
funny it was depressing because like
we've been playing so long that was a
feel like if I beat it with you or
Griffin or Frank or anybody else right
so like it would have been great because
what this dude it was like he was so
frustrating to both of us that's the
lighthouse for the guy the game is like
achieving whatever even it's amazing
though even things that you've done
countless times yeah like remember those
days always first started doing we were
doing crota
oh yeah that was just our thing it was
the sword person
like that we finally get it you know
when you get them really close and you
just know you've got a that was the most
frustrating is when you get super close
to killing the raid boss and so one
person would [ __ ] up is stressful today
I feel like in rates do a lot like even
the aurochs one I feel like it would get
glitchy sometimes yeah you would fall
through the platforms even when they're
supposed to be there and I swear to God
the most time when I did that rate we'd
have to the two first runs we'd get
super [ __ ] close and then we'd like
we would get worse yeah and it would go
on even longer like just know that would
work and I feel like people's attention
spans like if your attention spans not
in it and you can't keep the consistency
it's it gets worse machine with their
own friends yeah
so rectify you know how you you know how
you have to like jump to that platform
at the end you know cuz the boss you
know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah Tiny's
feels like a hunter or something I'm
gonna be the one you know and then like
you hear that one guy get frustrated it
doesn't only get frustrated and you play
with somebody would be like what
happened yeah yeah and you have to be
the ones talking down yeah yeah I was
like we were playing the raids early on
and it's like one of us with died
Stevenage don't want to say anything cuz
you already feel bad you know I talked
about me - I'm saying all of us I'm
saying like when we would do bad yeah
and you're like like especially when we
play early days of Bob and everybody
yeah
okay you know you're trying to play
following Steve Steve Schuh or he was
launcher and I remember the last round
of quadrant I had my you know I had my
suros rocket launcher and tell you you
guys were because this gets overwhelming
yeah hiding down to rock or trying to
avoid the cube and I remember I go you
know what Steve be a hero
positive heavy ammo now and I didn't
tell you guys but I popped my heavy
Moe and I skated yeah I didn't jump I've
been a bunny hop and then I mean they're
still hiding out and I [ __ ] hit in
the eyeball yeah screaming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]